what is the same take c5
i mean i think it's all the same um
very crazy
it's very desperate but what exactly do
you want if i just uh protect the bishop
for someone in this fight
not clear
true
maybe it's just not good for okay let's
see a b once again a b
yeah but okay it's just uh
maybe you suck some exchange yeah like
bishop e3 you said yeah but you have to
transforming it as it's a sacrifice
you're pretending it was a sacrifice
yeah and then when the game ends then
people decide depending on the depending
on the results yes yes
yeah
no but this is really scary for why that
knight e4 c5 is is there yeah yeah look
at john's face look at his face there is
this uh he sees he's he's he sees it
look at dan's face yeah he thinks
mountains blunder taking a nice fight
look at his face look at his face oh oh
oh oh oh guys guys guys guys maybe zero
one coming
jan is totally uh totally on fire
his face
you know he's happy enough and his body
language woke up again